Oh today we're starting with the apology
and you probably looked at your reading
lists so you see that we have quite a
few works by Plato and you know if you
if you think about your your Western Civ
classes or history classes whatever it
is that you've had previous to this you
know where Plato fits in he's in ancient
Greece and why are we reading him first
well he's one of the first philosophers
all right Aristotle is going to come
after him Epictetus and that the curious
will come later and so on down the line
and you can place them in a succession
and that's one way to make a sense of
these things and I will be posting some
things like timelines for you in in the
next couple of weeks to help you figure
that out but why are we beginning with
this particular dialogue some of this
I'm going to you know want some some
response from you some of this I'm just
going to sort of file through so I don't
assume that anybody here knows that much
about Plato or platonic dialogues or how
they're organized or anything like that
right this is a basic introductory class
so I shouldn't have I shouldn't presume
anything along those lines but you can
relate this to to other things that you
have studied chronologically it makes
sense to look at this dialogue first
chronologically music in order what else
know somebody else a time Chronos is is
Greek for time so a chronology is sort
of a structured order to things like a
schedule in this case we're looking at
the you know why pick on this particular
point in time you know Socrates and
Plato I'm not sure if all of you know
this they were not the first
philosophers philosophy had been going
on in Greece for quite a while not
necessarily on the Greek mainland but
other parts of Italy to speak in the
world so why aren't we starting at those
guys other than the fact that this is an
intro class and we only have you know 15
weeks and we have to pack these in yeah
yeah that's that's a good way to think
about I mean major in a sense they'll
get to the other people that we would
look at they're called pre-socratics
Socrates is so important that we look at
everything
before him as as pre-socratic free
Socrates sort of the way in you know
reckoning BC and AD right Socrates sent
a sort of point or you know in ancient
Rome they would they would count from
the founding of the Roman Empire they
were important but there was something
different about them there was something
lacking that Socrates and Plato brought
to the fore Socrates gets credited for
as they say bringing philosophy down to
earth we're gonna see a contrast in this
dialogue between Socrates as the person
who's very concerned with with human
matters and the kind of wisdom that's
possible for human beings and if you
were to read some of these pre-socratic
philosophers like st. Parmenides or
Heraclitus they were concerned with much
broader metaphysical topics they wanted
to know what things were made of
fundamentally not just you know this
desk is made out of wood or my body is
made on flash or a certain elements they
wanted to know what was the basic
building blocks of things what would
explain change would explain the passing
of time those sorts of things but they
weren't very systematic they didn't
leave a lot behind and they spent a lot
of time you might say that their head of
the clouds as a matter of fact one one
of them pathologists actually got made
fun of because he used to do so much sky
gazing he he fell them too I think it
was either a ditch or well now that he
got his revenge because all that sky
gazing
to predict something well we're a long
to predict what do you think one of the
something came up well I mean I mean the
sun's gonna come right but if you're if
you're paying close attention to the
seasons you might be able to predict
weather's gonna be and he did and he
figured out when it was gonna be a
really good olive harvest and he bought
up all the presses he established a
monopoly and then he made a fortune so
it just goes to show you some of that
stuff could be useful Socrates is not
concerned with this or a thing he's
concerned with yeah sure he's concerned
with more human issues who's wise what
is wisdom when you see in this dialogue
about what is justice what is courage
what's the right kind of way to live
those are things you don't have to know
much about chemistry or you know
cosmology the nature of the universe in
order to think about right people think
about these things all the time and you
guys get into arguments guaranteed every
single one of you has been in some
argument with somebody about how you
want to behave or how you want to live
so Socrates is bringing philosophy down
to earth Plato then Plato becomes very
concerned with what we call metaphysics
which is you know the sort of study of
what's ultimately real what's what's
most existent or true or underlying
everything else and he does something
new as well first of all he writes
things down Socrates never wrote
anything down
so everything that we've got from
Socrates and Plato is not coming from
Socrates actually writing stuff and then
plate up taking it
it's from from you know Plato either
hearing it from somebody or he was there
or he made some of it up using Socrates
is a character in some cases
but Plato does something different he
works things out systemically so if you
if you read only this dialog you're not
going to see that but if you read more
in more of Plato you get to see the the
scheme come together you start to see
things applying to each other parts
fitting into each other that's what it
means to be systematic he also looked at
these earlier thinkers these
pre-socratics and he sometimes said well
I think they were perfectly right about
this but partly wrong about this he was
being critical and to be critical in
philosophy doesn't mean just to be mean
or you know to cut people down or things
like that it means to look at things
very closely and to try to figure out
where is somebody actually correct
where is somebody in to correct it's
very rare that somebody's entirely
correct that the position that they have
is unassailable there's usually
something wrong it's very rare to find
somebody who's totally you know
absolutely wrong
- there's usually some truth in what
they're saying so that's what Plato did
with his predecessors the other thing
that he did that was that was new is he
worked philosophy through Donald walks
how many of you started going ahead and
reading the credo so far what do you
notice that's different between this
piece and the credo it's all done this
one we call it a dialogue but it's not
really a dialogue ISM there there's a
portion of it that's of dialogue where
Socrates is cross-examining one of his
accusers but for the most precious
psychology is giving a speech and you
can kind of see sometimes a lot recce
humor counts well I talked to so-and-so
and I said this and he said this but
it's not the actual dialogue taking
place with the credo Socrates is where
he's in jail he's in his prison cell
because the apology things didn't turn
out the way he'd hoped or maybe they did
and he's talking with credo
I mean he's also talking with another
character
do you remember okay that it's going to
be quite interesting when it when it
does take place but it's all dialogue
for the most part Plato's words are
dialogues like that they're like a play
all of you you remember back in
literature classes you've got some
Shakespeare or you read someone be able
to read this or that with most plays can
you tell what the author thought about
things
we're not think about Shakespeare for
example yeah just from sometimes the way
they express a little write about a
particular issue is through it just sort
of a sort of okay
yeah and so that would be in part your
child right you somebody's mocking
somebody else
somebody's praising somebody else what
if you've got several different
characters and some of them are praising
a person and the others are saying this
person's a terrible you know horrible
murderer liar pick whatever you want how
do you tell what the author thinks that
yeah oh you don't know how do you how do
you figure that maybe sometimes the the
author doesn't want shoots into exactly
what they or they want you to think
about both sides they those dialogues
you can usually figure who's going to be
the guy that is representing Plato
Socrates right but Plato is is pretty
fair he'll put good arguments in other
people's mouths because he wants you to
think about them he wants his readers to
try to see if there if there are is
something there Socrates doesn't always
win there are a few dialogues where he
but writing dialogues that was something
new in philosophy in a quota we don't
actually have these dialogues but some
of the other people that you're going to
read from what we know from ancient
authors berestov wrote dialogues to
apparently we don't have any of them
unfortunately because they're supposed
to have been very good that the curious
is supposed to written dialogues this is
this Claude on is a way to try to teach
people yeah it's part of what we model
in in class that's why it's important he
have the participation the back so far
you guys are just you know raising
single points or asking questions but I
encourage you to just begun to engage in
dialogue what else is it good to start
with this one well it can be kind of
useful because it's easier than some of
the Plato's other texts again because
it doesn't have a lot of different
voices its Socrates pretty much all the
way through it's a pretty easy to grasp
situation and not in the sense that any
of you are hopefully doing hopefully
none of you are going to be in such a
situation on trial for your life right
but it's an easy enough situation for
you to make sense of somebody is accused
of committing a crime they're defending
themselves they're explaining their
actions they're explaining why people
are prejudiced against them so that's
one that's easy to get it also contains
a couple good arguments and couple bad
arguments so it's it's a nice training
ground for you
for instance later on we're gonna look
at those arguments about death some of
the arguments Socrates makes aren't very
good arguments at all and and we'll walk
through that in in the class it could be
because of things that are left out it
could be because of you know verbal
sleight of hand and you can ask yourself
why does that happen the other the other
reason why we start with this is it's a
really good dialogue for introducing it
to who's this guy Socrates why is he
important he was just a Athenian living
back in the fourth fifth century why
should we care about him what did what
did he do well you know we can learn a
little bit about his stance how
philosophy in some ways comes out of
what Socrates is doing Plato catches the
fever or philosophy from this guy
Socrates and it wasn't because Socrates
was good-looking or you know anything
like that if you have any have you ever
seen any images of Socrates oh I'll put
some
kind of face with you to that why
well the always just seems like a really
old man you're understanding that I
think he's odd yeah he's really he's
really is that hideous but he's ugly but
there was something very very attractive
about his personality you know often we
say you know hi you know this person is
not good-looking with the other nice
personality that was a case of Socrates
why would people so attracted to that's
part of what we we need to think about
why do people want to have him around he
becomes kind of a hero and the apology
is one of the points the credo also the
apology was one of the points where he
is entering into history as kind of a
hero or a model for example and I'll
just give you a few examples of some
people that were gonna look at over the
course of the semester and also one who
were not and how Socrates affected them
you know Plato of course is very
impressed by Socrates and Plato they was
a rich very good-looking strong plant
Pato is actually coming from Sun his
original name it means broad you know he
was a big brawny guy and he had all the
advantages in life so what did he do he
gave him up and running around with this
old man and then spread his his ideas
here and there so Plato is one of the
people whose influence is fine but
Socrates left some other people behind
another one's another one of his
followers
his name was antistick and antis Tania's
found as a school called the cynic
school you know when we're talking about
cynicism we use the word in a slightly
different way than they did back in the
Greek times but the cynics were devoted
to trying to live a life of virtue and
truth and stripping away everything that
was false from their lives a life of
non-attachment
a life you know being honest with
yourself and being honest with others
intestine he's got this from Socrates
and that goes on eventually
influences another school that we're
going to study during this this class
called the Stoics
one of the people who's influenced by
the Stoics who becomes over a major
stoic philosophers Epictetus who are
going to read and Epictetus considered
socrates to be sort of a model for what
the ideal philosopher ought to be like
what the ideal life later on you know
fast-forwarding socrates is one of those
people that Christian thinkers worried
about why do you think they've worried
about it and he's long dead right by the
time the christianity shows up on the
scene why would they be concerned other
than you know he's an interesting guy to
read there were some things along those
lines as a matter of fact well set some
of Socrates Plato's philosophy if you
read it in a certain way it leads to
Gnosticism right but Plato is also
called the divine playdough by a lot of
Catholic and Orthodox theologians
because they took so much of this
philosophy wasn't there the end of it
there or you just comb her hair what
could you be concerned about and if
somebody who's long dead let's say let's
say you you adopt you know sort of like
Christian perspectives on the afterlife
I'll give you some of them some gang so
let's say we accept the Christian notion
of heaven hell unless you and your near
there eternally where do you think
Hitler is anybody think he doesn't have
anyone want you know if you had a place
of that would you place it on that
anybody think he's probably know
probably a good chance of that now
nobody actually minds Hitler being in
hell do you know what about Socrates
let's say you're a medieval Christian
thinker you're working to say within the
Catholic Church
you know Eastern Orthodox Church and
you're you're studying Plato and you
think to yourself wow you know this guy
said a lot of things that sounded an
awful lot like st. Paul what he seems
have been a really good guy
it's a shame he's in hell this is what
we called the problem of the virtuous
pagans what would God do with and this
is you know not an issue we're actually
to explore in the class I just want to
bring it up to you something that people
talked about would have been you know
what about people who didn't know the
you know the Christian religion didn't
have an opportunity to but they lived
really good lives you know supremely
good God saying sorry you missed you
missed your chance that's open
philosophical and theological questions
so Socrates took up you know a lot of
thought that way he was sort of the
example of the virtuous pagan for
Kierkegaard who were going to read at
the very end of the semester he saw
Socrates as what he call the teacher the
model of of the teacher and if you ever
hear your professors talking about well
how do I teach I teach
- socratic the Socratic method what are
they doing they're modeling themselves
Bluff of Socrates who at least you know
as far as Plato seems to think thought
that the truth was within all of us and
it just required some some cultivation
some asking questions some challenging
people to get them to be able to bring
it forth if they had it within them
Nietzsche on the other hand who we're
not gonna unfortunately get to read this
semester he thought Socrates was
actually a terrible guy with Socrates
and this Greek play like playwright
Euripides philosophy and culture and all
that just went to help and it's been
going downhill ever since Socrates was
an emblem of everything that was was
wrong because of his method because of
what he he did so we're gonna see this
in the apology that we're looking at
today so let's actually look at the
apology what are the official charges
what's he up to things yeah baby isn't
right corrupting the youth exactly so
taking the young people of the society
and making them worse right these are
the official charges that he's facing
who's bringing them these these young
men who are fairly ambitious they're
kind of you know up-and-coming mover and
shaker types mellitus
anteus and a few others and why do they
bring these charges well it's about time
somebody did something about this
Socrates guy and the sort of things that
he's bringing about especially with you
and these two are kind of connected
together aren't they because if your
society is a fairly religious society
then messing around with the religion
and teaching things that go that's gonna
be corrupting the you know this woman
and if you're corrupting the youth
you're kind of getting them ready for
their doing against societal norms going
against things that we ought to to all
believe
so he gets mellitus to actually say
something I don't know if you guys
caught that when you're looking at the
actual dialogue portion there's kind of
a question what is what does it mean
atheism and you notice that what do we
what are we usually we say yeah yeah no
belief in God or anything divine and
that's what Ana latest eventually says I
think you don't believe in any gods you
think that the moon is just a rock so on
what else is a possibility what else the
Socrates
maybe believes in gods but yeah baby
people means yeah maybe he believes in
the wrong gods maybe he doesn't believe
in the gods of that culture of that city
maybe he's teaching something that goes
against the religious orthodoxy but he
gets the latest to say no no I mean you
you don't believe in anything Socrates
as a matter of fact you're teaching what
is corrupting the youth opposed to it
let's dialogue will be the opposite of
corrupting yeah although it doesn't
necessarily have to be about the gods
correct if I if I corrupt you
I could corrupt you in a lot of
different ways maybe I you know if I
structure my philosophy class so all of
you come in here you know with a strong
religious faith and you leave here
believing in nothing or on the other
hand maybe you come in here believing in
nothing and I get you to believe in some
some weird cult all right I'd be
corrupting you
that would be in terms of religion but
there's other ways I could corrupt you
two aren't there you know get you all
the start smoking not not so many in
your generation isn't my generation when
I was in college believe it or not this
is gonna sound bizarre you guys I was a
smoker and the after class would end we
would light up in the classroom and we
were dashing our you know soda cans and
if you wanted to have a talk with the
professor you just come up and the
professor probably be smoking too and
you know you couldn't smoke well class
was in session and then they passed a
law that said you can't smoke in public
buildings and we never realized just how
bad we smokers had made it for the
non-smokers and just how much his there
was
in our main classroom building because
you could tell the difference after just
a couple of days and then you know
within a year we realized our behavior
been really crazy lighting up all the
time and the generation before mine
the professor's used to smoke while they
would teach yeah when was that
particular smoking walk past then well
that was in Wisconsin and that was in
1992 I think different states passed
different different laws at different
times I I was in college from 92 94 so
it was like right in the middle of mine
but but yeah they used to actually have
ashtrays in classrooms for the
professor's because you know David so
nowadays we see smoking is a terrible
terrible place right it's not only
healthy they get you to believe it's
healthy interrupted you not only
unhealthy but you know it makes you
stink and it makes you kind of a
degenerate to do and you know you've
probably all been exposed to this this
sort of thing so if I get you to all
become smokers I'm corrupting you aren't
I so I that could be instead of
corrupting with youth what you're doing
they should be teaching improving what I
mean there's a lot of different things
that that we could improve this isn't
the sort of class that's going to
improve your financial position there
are classes that you could take here I
think that probably would finance right
what
what would you be improving by hanging
out with
which you think is good and what how you
knew things how you live your life I
guess that's a good answer anything what
do you think is good so beliefs about
good and bad right and wrong perhaps
even about the noble or them shameful or
something like that and I'm going to say
the actions behavior and how you live
your life how do you live your life okay
yeah so we have Socrates is corrupting
the youth he is making the rest of us
more it's not a man at all smoking it's
a matter of like killing people or
stealing or lying about people or
causing discord
that's what corrupting the youth would
it would actually be what is what do we
know that he actually does with the
youth from the text what what is what is
this characterization there's some of
them he doesn't like like malade it's
Molina's it's a young man but Molina's
doesn't like socrates either one of
these young men do like Socrates yeah
yes and then what happens that that way
it's off isn't that bad right there's
providing an audience although you know
providing an audience would be a problem
because it turns out the people who are
being questioned don't like it
a little bit further don't they what do
you remember if you see somebody doing
something well then you hang out with
them while they're doing that you're
gonna start we're gonna start doing it
and now Socrates is a bit more gentle at
least according to himself right then
these young men and it makes sense
doesn't it young young people I mean
you're all young people I remember what
it was like to be young I was real
hothead
I get people's faces about things argue
with them and shout and don't they ever
get a fight over philosophy my dad did
not not over Socrates or Plato or
anything like that he actually got in a
fight and I was gone so far was good or
not he was holding that he ever was not
there was good this is a more common
belief that well the young men they
they're pretty aggressive they go after
people a lot more aggressively than
Socrates does Socrates is doing it
because what why is he doing it so he
can learn so we can learn he wants to to
know so the young men have maybe that
motive but they also have some other
yeah you know he doesn't say that in the
dialogue but that's probably a good
supposition because these are these are
young men who look up to Socrates and so
how do you you know prove your worth you
try to show it you can do the same sort
of thing but that's an interesting
conjecture what does anyone remember
what Socrates actually says why they do
around questioning people now sort of
freelancing because they like it because
it's fun because it's entertaining you
know to take people who think they know
and tear them down maybe the people who
do know because they're you know if
they're not quick enough on their feet
to defend themselves against an argument
these young men you know and tear them
down think about I've got sort of a
comparison here think about comedy what
is it who is most comedy gentle in your
experience anybody who ever going to a
comedy club only a few you should go it
it's I don't actually like going because
I don't like conflict that much people
will get in conflict at comedy clubs and
it'll happen a couple different ways
sometimes the comic will start you know
picking on people in the audience that's
one sure way to get a laugh some comics
actually like you know their whole show
is like that other comic comics will get
heckled from the crowd because the crowd
will say things to them and they'll
start saying things back and forth or
you know comics will do what they'll
make fun of other people that aren't in
the room it's it's actually pretty rare
that you find comedy that isn't at the
expense of somebody now the ancient
Greece especially in Athens they had
comedy and there are comedies
haven't you ever read any
three comedies like Aristophanes works I
hope that you do your college career we
tend to think of these ancient Greeks as
if you know whether they were a lot
earlier than us so they they don't know
anything about perversion or you know
bloodiness or you know rude behavior or
anything like that read one of
Aristophanes place you'll see that
anything goes no-holds-barred and they
have special time to do this
it was during certain festivals they
didn't do it all the time during Greek
comedies during these these plays they
would actually have a portion of the
play where they'd all wear masks at the
time because they're all familiar with
those those masks you know tragedy masks
and the comic mess they would take him
off and then he'd come out into the
audience and they would say hey you you
voted for that measure last month that
was really stupid here's why and by the
way your wife blah blah blah blah blah
that's the way Greek comedy was people
put up with that because it was within
certain limits now imagine you've got
this guy Socrates he's doing something
kind of funny and kind of entertaining
and he's got all these followers who are
going around and imitating him but
they're doing so in such a way as to
maybe get away from the spirit of what
Socrates was about and they're deriving
a lot of enjoyment from it surprising he
didn't get himself killed earlier if
that was the case isn't it in a society
where that's how you do settlements so
these are the the old the new charges
with the old charges
let's get invited yeah and the entire
thing is is like atheism it's not
treating divine things rightly there's
some other charges that that Socrates
actually brings up word for word he says
some people say that he's a wise man who
speculated about the heaven above and
searched into the earth beneath so he's
he's wise and into nature and that could
be in pious because you know a lot of
people thought that natural phenomena
were the work of the gods or actually
manifestations of the gods
as a matter of fact one of the dialogues
that we were going to look at but we're
not gonna have time to the Euthyphro is
all about piety and impiety piety is the
proper attitude towards the gods or
toward divine things the impiety is the
wrong attitude towards what else they
also say that he makes the worse
we should probably put it in here for
Memphis here how many of you feel that
you're terrible an argument that you
can't convince people of anything okay
how many of you would say great ass like
your honor debate team or you know
you'll get in arguments with people just
because you like you know doing that and
you know you're very competent what
about the rest of your all more or less
in the middle you've all countered
people who can take a bad argument and
make it sound good right you may have
been bested by them at one time Connor
let's do this but people also do it in
politics that do it and debating about
things they do the personal
relationships sometimes people get
talked into doing things yeah it seems
like a good thing at the time because
somebody convinces them right that's
making the worst argument or the worst
cause look better and there was a whole
class of people who did this
professionally in Socrates time called
the Sophists or the rhetorician so
they're saying that he's one of those
what else
he also said well they say I'm a teacher
which is but then he keeps money for
teaching no why would that be a bad
thing I'm getting paid okay of course I
have to live them
Socrates didn't yet he was more or less
tgd anything worthwhile it's all fake
what he's saying yeah if you were this
is this applies to your university
education you guys are actually paying
pretty good money for the education that
you're gonna compare to people going out
of state school right
it's a private school you want to be
getting something back so if you get
some professor who doesn't give you a
syllabus and just breezes in and talks
about some stuff and then you know dad's
writing a paper and then walks out
you're probably going to feel cheated in
aren't you yeah if you get to the end of
the semester and you don't have and you
put in your work and you put in your
time and you don't have anything where
you can say this is definitely what I
learned in this class and here's what
I'm going to take to the next class
again he'll feel cheated somebody took
your money and they didn't they didn't
give you something in return well that
was a big problem at the time the
Sophists were teaching and taking money
so these are the other charges and who's
making these these charges against them
well just about everybody any he points
to you know the comic playwright who
made fun of them actually his friend
Aristophanes but well well just about
everybody who's Socrates has crossed
they're saying these things for the
younger kids the ones who are bringing
the charges they believe this stuff and
why are people going to vote against him
because they believe this stuff too but
what's the real motive for them what's
their real animus against Socrates what
did he do that was wrong in their eyes
one of the core points about
yeah yeah
and it's interesting you said why is
enough first now you know nothing right
and then there's sort of a play in there
if you read the dialogue through several
times you'll see he kind of fluctuates
between not knowing anything these
people don't know anything at all and
well some of them know something but not
enough
and then he claims that he does know
something by not knowing something which
is a little what we call paradoxical how
do people feel when you take with what
they claim about themselves you show
that it's wrong yeah
so if I if I think that I'm a great
singer and you listen to me
and I sound terrible you say you know
and you are not a good singer I think
you should just stick to doing the
philosophy bit now if my egos involved
I'll get angry at all my feelings I'll
be insulted what happens when we get
angry this isn't actually talked about
in the dialogue but think about your own
experience you guys let everything go if
any of you've ever been shown up like
that somebody made you made you look bad
something that you felt yourself to be
good in
you'd be angered with them or hurt if
you hold on to that what does it turn
into yeah the garage and the garage is a
form of hatred hatred is stronger than
anger hatred is more elastic like
Aristotle says the angry person wants
the other person to suffer the person
who hates wants them not to even exist
they want off the man and this is what
these people want with Socrates because
he's standing in the way of their their
identity they were feeling about this
you know the same thing could happen
with studying philosophy I hope that
over the course of the semester
someone beliefs that you have about
yourself will get called into question
and maybe change or maybe hold on to it
if they're good beliefs and you call
them into question they'll stand up to
it right but you won't know unless you
actually do question them you examine
them living what Socrates called the
examined life so who does he go around
you actually before we talk about that
let's let's look at this this narrative
where does he where does not Socrates go
where does this friend go that starts
this whole chain of events in this
narrative the Oracle right so this
involves religion and you notice
Socrates isn't really any ideas Disney
because he believes that the the God at
Delphi Apollo actually is giving him
something that he has to think about
it's something he has to do he actually
says the God can't lie because it would
be against the God's nature so he
doesn't leaving gods and he does believe
some things that seem to be pretty on
track about about the gods so a counter
front is kind of what we'd call smartass
so he goes and he asked the Oracle at
Delphi about this Socrates guy is there
anyone wiser than him
says no and he comes back they tell
Socrates I guess what guess what I found
out you're the wisest guy in Greece and
Socrates says well I think that doesn't
make any sense and there you actually
see an argument
don't you let's reconstruct that article
so nobody
what does Socrates then start how does
the chain of reasoning go from there
the Oracle said nobody is wise but I'm
not wise so maybe the guy that's wrong
right but the guy can't lie so there
must be something going on here how
could anybody you know it doesn't think
that they're wise be wise well how is
Socrates wise how does it turn out what
is his wisdom consistent it's kind of
against paradoxical it's it's a thought
where it almost seems to contradict
itself yes
yeah so we're going to directions with
us Socrates is wise he is really wise
because know what about the other people
who Socrates guys should be wiser than
me right they claim to be wise I don't
claim to be wise yeah and we just say
they're deluded about their own wisdom
so they're worse off right they send
people who believe that were worse off
Socrates is actually he's not actually
attaining any great wisdom but at least
he knows what his limitations are these
other people don't and now let's think
about who are these these people it may
be very hard for you to relate to these
these groups of people at the start who
are the people who're the classes and
people that he goes to yeah
politicians yeah
yeah that's the last week you ready
and sometimes I miss conference I do and
then if you catch it a little bit later
on he'll actually slip in a fourth group
which is the rhetorician so this when
he's talking what he was talking about
who's he actually bringing the
indictment against him and why they're
doing whose behalf now politicians we
know who they are right every four years
every two years we elect some of them
local politicians these are the people
who make things happen within society
imagine now a state that's very small
think about say Rhode Island instead of
like the state of New York which is
pretty vast Rhode Island's pretty small
I think it's only got three counties in
each one of those counties you know it's
sort of like a city state almost and
then the larger municipality when you've
got a state that small you could know a
lot about the people who you're electing
New York it's a bit harder isn't it yeah
the huge state yeah New York City just
you know dominates everything because
it's got so many people the politicians
we can't even wrap our heads around what
does he mean by artisans what do you
think he means there
is that so
tradespeople perhaps me so for instance
in our day plumbers electricians iron
workers would be artisans it's perhaps
of an unfortunate word choice for the
translation because it makes me think of
like people out there painting and doing
things like that they would actually be
closer to the poet's reparations have
any of you ever been a rhetorician you
have actually read at least met somebody
to study rhetoric all of you in high
school English teachers right one of the
things you can specialize in English is
what we call rhetoric and Composition
retcons
and what they study are how to use
language persuasive that's what rhetoric
is now think about in our society who
would use this language persuade
persuasively besides people in politics
they they of course do right you have
some people who do with speech that's
what the reparations did back then but
we have a lot more of this in our
society ancient Greeks there
we're else do you find rhetoric being
used every single day okay boy yeah the
business world especially in in finance
advertising yeah I was gonna say I was
looking for marketing but advertising is
even broader bring this housing yeah so
the business like sales yes sales would
also be actually sales to be somewhat
more like the classic reparations
because they tend to be working more
directly with language
with crowds but marketing advertising
all of that fits into radishes they're
trying to use language to persuade
people as a matter of fact every time
you see one of those public service yeah
it doesn't always have to be a product
it can just be you know or you know
don't drink and drive
if they're if they're sculpting in such
a way as to not really give you an
argument
we're just appeal to to your emotions
they're they're effectively doing
rhetoric I mean some of those ads are
pretty great I like the ones where they
they open up the car although you know
the liquor pours out you know I find
myself wanting that you know to know
which kind of link here it's going to be
now this game's beer this guy's wine
this guy it's clearly you know some sort
of whiskey
they're great hands but all they really
are is is rhetoric this leaves us with
the talking one the Greeks had poets we
have moments right where did weird poets
hang out coffee shops right new poetry
slams
maybe they published in literary
magazines what are poets like we stay
with joke back when I was in college one
thing a poet hates the most is another
for weird poets like in our society we
have a lot of them do we Greeks don't
actually mean the same thing that
polished yes
somebody hit on the corner scribbling
versus I've done it I raise your right
silence
actually I still do that's not what they
don't even know what was Greek poetry
like what did what did that mean have
any of you read The Odyssey or the Iliad
didn't read like a poem yeah yeah it
rhyme but it doesn't in Greek it
actually doesn't rhyme it'sit's the
metre movie in English we use and Ryan
it's called The Odyssey the Iliad the
Amen
those are all examples of epic Beowulf
is an epic that's a kind of poetry I
think Germanic languages actually is
what's called stop or stress reliable
the Nibelungen we eat if you've read
that you know the story these Germans
fighting each other that's an epic we
have a lot of epics don't we so how are
we like our epics we can read some of
them how do we really get movies yeah if
you want it to be truly epic it's got to
be at least two hours miniseries
they had other kinds of poetry as well
what we call lyrical poetry which is you
know sort of expressive of the
individual condition well state plays we
watch plays we watch more plays than the
Greeks did you watch our plays on
television they're just you know filmed
and edited they're not so much live
dramatic performances which tend to be
kind of highbrow right the stuff that
forms our popular culture is what would
count as poetry so this is this class of
poets is much broader than what we think
what about our whole music industry do
you know any people who perhaps guide
their lives a little bit too much by
songs by a particular artists think
about love songs and the message is that
so many of them have and what the
effects would be if you actually
followed some of the the advice or put
yourself in the narrative of some of
those love songs
some of them might turn out ok a lot of
them would turn out pretty terrible you
know I'm gonna stay with you forever
even though you cheat on me treating you
wrong I still love you is that healthy
that wise I don't think so I hope none
of you do now Socrates is going to these
people so they have different roles in
our society but these classes are still
there and what happens he goes first the
politicians they claim to know they
claim to be wise what are they wise
about
what does politics really about if
you're kind of jaded you might say it
making money we're putting people under
your thumb
crushing how do you manage society yeah
there's a lot of different ways you
could go with that and people always
have different ideas about it so
politicians are the ones who say hey
look I've got the best ideas you should
vote for me let me do what I think we
ought to do or enact my policies and you
know they think it's peaches or they
give policy statements they're making
claims to wisdom they're making claims
not only this is the best thing to do at
the time what do they base their here's
what the good is for human beings here's
the better way to live
and Socrates goes and he asks them to
you know clarify what it is that they're
saying and turns out that at least in
ancient Athens but I'll let you think
about whether this is the case of our
society or not maybe we don't have to
extrapolate what Socrates did there
there he doesn't find anybody who
satisfies him and he actually says you
know there were a lot of inferior people
people who didn't have positions of
power who seem to know an awful lot more
than these politicians that don't this
is where that that issue about is the
wisdom absolutely not their word is
there's some degree of wisdom that's
where that comes in he says there were
some inferior people who seemed wiser so
if you're saying they're wiser they must
have some degree of wisdom what about
the poet's they're not quite in the same
case as the politicians he treats the
politicians pretty properly they don't
know anything
so the poet's know anything they don't
know they don't know about the most
important thing which is what they're
generating you ask them to explain what
are you talking about here as well
I don't know you know and Socrates says
well you know they're divinely inspired
it just comes to that and I can't really
give you could ask yourself is that true
in our society whether are their state
musicians who write songs and you ask
them what is this song really about if
they can't explain it
let's see some of you said they were
divinely inspired
yeah but then Socrates was charged as me
yeah so well the church doesn't doesn't
hold up very well yeah yeah I mean that
there's all these points throughout the
whole thing where mellitus must have
just been like you know wincing and
wishing he hadn't charged in with a
theism here's gonna hope that the other
charge would would stick the poets don't
know about their own production what
they do know about about something so
the craftsman good he said that the
poets knew how to play please the people
they didn't know what they were talking
about but they knew saying yeah then the
trades people are a little bit different
they do know something an electrician
does know about electricity where to put
the condom because if they screw it up
what happens they don't stay on
electrician for very long do they the
Potter actually knows how to make
pottery where did they go wrong
[Music]
they found the same errands of poets
what was that
like they you're on the right track they
claim to know more than they really did
yeah so because somebody is a really
good electrician who knows how society
got to be right because the signing is
pretty much like an electrical box you
know or if they're a Potter you know
your your love life isn't going well
well it's like this pot that I threw all
the time
sometimes you just got to take the the
you know ruin stuff and throw it back in
the kiln because of human you know human
being in a relationship is just like a
pot you see the problem there people go
by what they do no I think they can
extend that to everything else
especially the most important things in
life so they actually did have some
wisdom didn't they it was let's skip
ahead a little bit and look at these
things about death now wisdom is going
to be one of the key themes throughout
this this semester knowledge wisdom who
has it what does it consist in we mean
by death is another important thing I
think I may set this to the ethics class
not to you guys this is a very morbid
thought but it's you know it's true if
you think about it I mean they actually
look around the room and all your fellow
students now every one of those people
one of three things is gonna happen in
relation to you you're gonna die before
they do they're gonna die before you do
or you're gonna die at the same time
because the mortality rate is a hundred
percent and death is one of those things
that hopefully all of you are very far
I'm closer because I'm you know twenty
years further on than you guys are death
is one of those things that we want to
know about a lot of people talking
yeah near-death experiences and what's
the other side like Socrates have some
discussions about that doesn't mean
there's two things I'd like you to take
away from this thinking left out one of
them is Socrates gives you some
arguments why dying isn't gonna be a bad
thing well look at those in a minute
he also says he doesn't mind dying in
part because it's not really doing him
any harm or great harm what would be
worse than dying for Socrates what's a
fate worse than death as we sometimes
yeah sort of indirectly because what is
that going to require of him that
stopped him doing philosophy okay now
that's these are both on the right track
he's talked about in terms of this is
unrighteousness which is another way of
translating injustice being over doing
wrong things to be a doer abroad is
worse than dying now that's kind of
strange thought isn't it so it depth of
be an unspeakable game game if it's no
consciousness whatsoever what's what's
does anything strike you as kind of odd
about the the game for who if you have a
consciousness are you gaining anything
are you enjoying anything there's really
no you to to benefit so that's kind of a
bad I mean you somebody could have
responded to side
what does he really think this is this
is what he actually does think that
death is a journey to another place and
now here again is where the not so much
living with your conscious but it is
kind of tied to honor the honor that
other people give you the afterlife
according to Socrates is going to be
either a good place or a bad place more
or less depending on what you bring to
it so if you're a bad person you're
going to show up in a place where you
know you can't trick people any more
into supporting you or thinking you're a
good person you can't fool yourself any
more you're going to be confronted with
people who actually know what justice is
these wise judges and they're going to
you know send you to a bad place or to a
good place and if you get sent to a good
place he says if the pilgrim arrives in
the world well if indeed when the
pilgrim arrives in the world below he's
delivered from the professors of justice
in this world these these people and
finds the true judges that pilgrimage
will be worth worth making what is he
going to get to do there I will be able
to continue my search into true or false
knowledge he has in this world so as a
man I will find out who really is wise
if these people here don't really
possess wisdom maybe once he gets down
to the afterworld the afterlife he will
encounter those who truly do have wisdom
and he says what infinite delight there
would be in conversing with them and
asking them questions we're in that
world they don't put a man to death with
us now so I'm going to leave you with
this image of Socrates down there
fathering all the people in Hades
drink down and not letting them go what
we're going to pick up with next week is
credo and credo begins in the prison
cell
the day before Socrates is supposed to
be executed then this one he's very
outspoken right the city you know I'm
the gadfly I get to poke the city and
make it jump when I need to in the credo
he was gonna say he has to obey the laws
even though the laws are going to put
him to death so think about that as
here's your reading through it and have
a good week